it's clear capitalism doesn't work very
well at the moment but most of us feel
there isn't anything to be done we're
stuck with it because there's just no
alternative that's nonsense
there are plenty of good workable
suggestions for reform and here are four
of them we have to bear in mind that
capitalism isn't just one thing there
are almost as many varieties of
capitalism as there are capitalist
countries there are American German
Singaporean Swedish Danish Korean
versions of the thing the differences
include the size of the welfare state
from around 10% of GDP in Korea to over
30% in Finland the importance of
state-owned enterprises producing less
than 1% of GDP in the US but 22% of GDP
in Singapore and the power of trade
unions with nearly 70 percent of workers
unionized in Norway and only about 10%
in the US capitalism has got dials and
we can adjust them think that sweeping
that supposedly high tax addicted
country only introduced income tax in
1932 two decades after the US and nearly
a century after Britain or remember that
the u.s. that throw rich pays today had
a top income tax rate of 91% between
1950 in 1963 and it didn't do them much
harm at all so we don't have to chuck
capitalism in the bin the trick is to
tweak and reform it in intelligent ways
when people hear of options to adjust
capitalism for the benefit of all they
tend to think that sounds beautiful but
in the end the freest variety that you
find in the US will ultimately
out-compete the others because it's just
superior the argument goes like this the
u.s. variety maximizes growth by
minimizing the constraints on wealth
creation which creates higher inequality
but in the end makes everyone better off
in absolute terms than under a more
equal but less dynamic system but if you
look at facts it's overwhelmingly not
true that the freer varieties of
capitalism grow faster from 1955 to 1980
the time when regulations were much
stricter the world economy grew
two-point-six percent per year for the
next 30 years the heyday of neoliberal
economics it grew at only 1.3 percent in
its miracle growth periods between 1958
and 1982 Japan Korea and Taiwan had
governments hell-bent on dictating
business activities and it worked rather
well for them contrary to the popular
that a large welfare state is bad for
economic growth finland with a welfare
state one and a half times bigger than
that of the u.s. 30 percent of gdp s
against a 20 has grown faster than the
US with an average annual per capita
income growth rate of 2.7 percent for
the last 40 years against 2% in the u.s.
a well-designed welfare state with
integral retraining and redeployment
programs promotes rather than deters
growth importantly when people feel
secure they take risks which is the
lifeblood of capitalism secure people
dare as the old slogan of the Swedish
Social Democratic Party used to go
unlike what some economists like to tell
us it doesn't have to be a hard choice
between security and stagnation on the
one hand and perilous in security and
economic dynamism it isn't some
inevitable natural phenomenon you
sometimes hear that CEOs need to have
huge pay packets or they won't deliver
the goods that data consistently shows
no relationship between the rise in
executive pay and executive performance
then there's the claim that
redistributing wealth impoverishes
everyone but some of the most productive
and wealthy countries in the world
redistribute avidly before
redistribution through the tax system
Germany in 2011 was a far more unequal
country than the US Germany's Gini
coefficient an indicator of income
inequality in which zero means absolute
equality and one means absolute
inequality was at no point five one
higher than in the US where it was not
point five but after redistributed taxes
Germany's Gini coefficient fell to
nought point two nine while the u.s.
with a far more elite friendly tax
system so its Gini coefficient fall to
only nought point three eight
moreover countries can limit the
variability of the market to generate
inequality through formal regulations or
informal business practices South Korea
for example has by far the lowest rate
of inequality in the developed world
with a Gini coefficient of just nor
point three four but this didn't come
about by magic rather because the
country has lots of regulations
protecting some pretty nice things like
organic farms and small shops especially
bakeries and Brook shops and it has laws
that keep CEO compensation low by
international standards all this
preventing the full manifestation of the
in equalizing
chances of an unfettered market in other
words inequality is not the result of
uncontrollable forces like technology or
international trade there are a lot of
tools that our society can use in order
to reduce it and a lot of the wealthiest
and most dynamic countries are using
them very wisely indeed already the rise
of the financial industry is a blight on
capitalism making it unstable unequal
and very short-term for example in the
1960s if an investable to share an ax
company in the UK they held on to it for
an average of five years by the
mid-2000s the number had fallen to a
mere 7 months faced with a radically
diminished patience of their investors
companies have done a host of nasty
things to make investors happy right now
at the expense of the long-term they
suppress wages squeeze suppliers and
Chuck back profit at shareholders rather
than reinvesting between 1950 in 1970
the hundred largest US corporations
retained 65 percent of their profits
every year but by the 2000s they were
retaining a mere six percent vastly
diminishing their own abilities to
invest for a properly successful future
it's actually rather easy to encourage
long-term oriented investment you just
need to keep greater voting rights and
tax advantages for long-term
shareholders and you need to have
sovereign wealth funds and national
pension funds representatives of the
long term collective interest using
their considerable financial power to
back long-term oriented corporate
behavior above all mergers and
acquisitions need to be made more
difficult as its the threat of these
that typically pushes managers towards
actions that please fickle short-term
investors all these schemes may seem
like pipe dreams but they're far more
tantalizing than this there are real
possibilities alive in certain favored
enlightened corners of the globe right
now there's no need to give up on
capitalism we just need to understand it
a little better and stand up to
arguments that bully us into accepting
its worst versions
you